having faced the specter of a political
and social earthquake france woke up to
life as normal emmanuel macron will
remain president even though plenty
voted for him simply to stop his rival
marine le pen
personally i'm very happy because i
wouldn't have wanted marine le pen to
become the president of france because
she's not capable of being president
they made us hostages
celebrated his triumph by promising to
be the president for all
but the reality is that france is
becoming increasingly fractured by
tribal political division
there were violent scenes in some cities
in the hours after macron's victory he's
a figure as divisive as the election
he's just one
the french society
i would say is nearly as polarized
as american society
and you can see that
the the the polarization
uh oppose
the have to the have-nots
and that is macron's great challenge to
unite this country to understand why a
radical pen ran him close
but this isn't just about how macron's
victory plays out here in france the
united kingdom will look for any new
policies on subjects such as
cross-channel migration
and the rest of the european union knows
mr macron as a die-hard fan of greater
european integration
just listen to what was playing as he
walked to the podium last night
it's ode to joy anthem of the european
union where the axis of france and
germany is so crucial
so what does europe's biggest country
make of macon's triumph that's a
question i put to germany's ambassador
to france
there's a clear signal you know that the
clear majority of those who went
to this vote
uh voted in favor of a clear european
orientation
of of france uh when it comes to europe
based also on the french german
relationship and that is something uh
emir mccomb based his whole campaign
very much on so that that's really very
reassuring for us when macomb
france felt charmed by him but this time
it's different
the affection is much more muted
[Applause]
[Music]
adam parsons sky news paris